don't know what I'm supposed to do
walking in circles
maybe I'm done here I mean what was I
supposed to do I forgot I redirected all
the water maybe I'm dumb
let's head it back and see
all right Thank You us
yes
I'll log out of C meanwhile
oh [ __ ]
okay
I doubt this gonna work
goddamnit can you climb any jump shot
ya know it's clear I don't really want
to go down here though
ah whoa what the [ __ ] oh it's poisonous
[ __ ] I can't go here [ __ ]
I didn't take any damage though I think
I need to clear the poison somehow
nope
i'ma just supposed to rush through
no that can't be
get up they Danielle
a nerd don't see the point in these
[ __ ] bridges but whatever
if you want alright we're back
let's see if I can stuck goddamnit
up
No
what the hell
Oh
oh I get it I get it I get it was delays
I saw that [ __ ]
and I will go like 360 boom
I think I got this
all right front run Danielle rut
yeah
did I not Oh goddamn it
get up
here we go okay
Hey
we we
all right 360 I can do this
oh [ __ ] why oh god what do I keep doing
that so stupid
just a [ __ ] waste of time
all right second attempt
not used to this sense
okay I got it now
hahaha what the [ __ ] was that
alright gonna try it again alright I got
this
your alpha oh jeez oh I made it awesome
told you I can told you morgue yeah you
want to go into the [ __ ] morgue
because that's not creepy
all right I wonder how a medieval war
more looks like do you see damn you
it has you live what the shadow yieldeth
has for now
let's get this out of here so we can get
some peace yes
let's wait to just down the corridor to
the mall
I want to go to the morgue no more
you did well Daniel
let's get going oh [ __ ] I guess we're
back to the creepy parts yay that bodies
everywhere are you
what
uh-huh
all this did with him
that's creepy
all right pick you up pick me up before
you go-go yeah nice
we're only explaining quite badly
goddammit
three day
get you
this room hey hey buddy
I read the share who's gonna come there
don't go there
the person
if not prayed my Heavenly Father will
take me in my sleep
slip that up
and go no this is where it came from
Carla so [ __ ] going in here I get
the feeling I got a bump in the my bro
bro
oh that's nice
you have a small dick I hear you
breathing
Daniel
you hear me tell you changed your mind
what is stiff from rigor mortis and it
can be older a day
what
gross
let's cut his penis off okay I'm not
going to do that
huh
oh another one of those I don't like
those
take this up first
Oh
come on
yes perfect Nina de it's all good all
right wha
vaccine enabling my men to work in funky
ridden sewer as Oh sunny the vaccine to
go to the sewers basically I get
what
what let's leave that alone don't trust
that Oh
Oh dead bodies why not
ah seriously
why the war
aah children screaming why not
oh this place is horrible Oh
Oh
who knows
what the hell this place flowers
what tell us up with that noise
ah [ __ ] there was nothing in here
baby screaming why not
it's going here
oh [ __ ]
stiff
oh sorry
the fine cartoon looks like a part of
our surgical tool so I'm going to
prepare
oh I might be able to use it on him it
cannot penetrate the skull
Oh oh wait I got this yeah that's
[ __ ] disgusting
no yeah are you kidding me
it's [ __ ] gross
there's the thing in your head dude it
looks happy though
the tube is then
I was a but nothing enough to penetrate
my skin my skin is he talking to me
you're dead dude
are you kidding me that actually worked
oh did I just inject myself with this
blood of that
Oh